okay what's going on everybody it's Sean
Evans from first we feast and it's a
very special day I'm joined by Dane drop
on YouTube his fast food reviews are
some of the most popular on the net he's
a pioneer and the drive-thru taste test
and today we're joining forces like
Voltron to review some of the most
popular hot and spicy fast food menu
items I'm sure that you've tried most of
these but it'll be a first time for me
are we ready to just dive right into it
as what we do so this is the fiery
Doritos locos taco what I like right off
the top hit me
des shell is coming for your Facebook
the very first bite is spicy and there's
nothing that's going to burn your soul
but you're going to fill it going down
like right now brah I'm getting a little
bit like we're over here I'm getting a
little bit of sizzle if you just want to
dip your toes into the shallow angles
right how warm the water is yeah I think
that this is a good place to start and
for those of you that like the extreme
life stand that Diablo 4 and then your
real truth are couple package our Diablo
sauce take it down I want a three and a
half wasn't killing me
well spicy was just okay to me so I gave
it a 3 I would just get the regular taco
it just doesn't come close enough to the
icon for me to take it all that
seriously here we have Burger King's
jalapeno chicken fries yes now y'all get
my chicken and get excited don't think
you coming up over here it's going to be
top off the KFC just buffing out with
chicken all over the place running and a
half but you have small chunks of
jalapeno that's been baked in so when
you take that first hit forget the
chicken you're gonna get that jalapeno
flavor and kickin up you're like the
jalapeno and black pepper oh you bet
that's a very like that I'm catching up
that's the type of flavor that pops you
all up in your face and makes you
respect the BK chicken game
seriously I like five all day how that
your boy oh right off the top jalapeno
all over and you know a couple seconds
in that says it a fireplace is going to
work I gave it a four with the beak a
chicken fries I'm eating them I'm
dipping them I'm snacking on them and I
can't eat half the box casually like
that and then disrespect it with a three
or a two you know that's a 4 that's a 4
all day I like that alright this is the
Wendy's spicy chicken sandwich and I
know the view at home you're like her
this isn't a new menu sometimes you have
to have the gold standard you have to
have the classic so you know what to
measure the new school against you know
I'm going to give them that line again
Wendy's heed this warning this is what's
keeping the ship afloat don't forget
where your bread is buttered whoo you
take that first bite through the soft
bun and then you're going to hit that
breaded work and that breaded work is
right up over the base your chicken
breast and it has to be a tender
fender-bender on the interior for you to
truly appreciate it it ain't too hot
I'm not burnt all up on the interior but
I'm getting a little bit of sizzle this
is a comfort and peace of spicy chicken
I'm feeling it over the stove all day
come play a game Wendy you know what
you're doing when it comes to the
chicken in a spicy chicken at that can't
argue with that at all it's a perfect
five for me to me the Wendy's spicy
chicken sandwich is an icon it's one of
the five best fast food menu items in
the world and what am I supposed to do
lie to the people out there I can't a
lot of the people out there is basically
a perfect fast-food sandwich we're
saving this for last and it was on
purpose because I'm so curious about
this here we have KFC Nashville style
fried chicken
now Nashville style is fried chicken but
very very hot fried chicken Prince is in
Nashville for example that's where it
kind of all started
you have Howland raised which I ate last
week in LA it's the hottest fried
chicken I've ever had in my life and
I've had some hot fried chicken kernels
I do not expect KFC to bring the heat
like that but I am curious what they've
done because kind of a sacred thing you
know I can already see that there's a
spice blend on this you can see the way
this changes color this is the spiciest
thing that we've eaten so far
my tongues kind of lighten up a little
bit if my tongues lighten up a little
bit I'm not having the spicy food games
but I could appreciate it
I would want a four piece again the
trick you can make him off that beat up
and win in my book I gave it a 3 and I
shouldn't hold it against can't see but
that dry ass biscuit cost of the sauce
well there it is
it's gospel if you heard it from Dame
you know that it's the truth make sure
that you subscribe game drops first we
feast Sean Evans game hold it up on ATM
machine like that so nobody eyeballing
my no-show